evil or Halal money I'm going to travel
the GTA 6 map of Miami interviewing as
many Muslim millionaires as I can find
out how we can get rich with good Halal
money just like them and that way I
don't got to sell feet
picks turn that [__] off [__] I
was getting changed you know what I'm
saying first stop the mosque cuz I don't
know where else I'd find
Muslims we'll work on the
left
[Music]
we went to the first mased and the
security guard told us to get so next
[Music]
place okay so we just got to the second
uh mosque it says it's a Pentecostal
Church of God and yeah I don't I don't
know it's uh says Christian there so to
the next
[Music]
mosque the mosque says it's on the on
the [__] highway how do you guys find
a place to pray none of these places are
on Google Maps properly they don't have
the hours you can't call them I thought
that this was like the building when I
looked at it it's the highway we went to
the highway bro in the hours it says
24/7 so I'm like all right a place to
like pray all the time that sounds lit
and then Sunday and Monday it said hours
might differ so I'm like maybe Sundays
and Mondays you know God's chilling and
he doesn't you know all right on the
mosque
[Music]
4 Mosk number four I am done today with
looking for mosques to get into um so I
just threw up an Instagram story I'm
looking for some Muslim millionaires to
get interviewed so I just throw that up
on my Instagram so we're going to wait
for some responses and yeah I'll keep
you guys posted 3 hours down the drain
driving to different mosques Hope was
running low and I never found anyone so
that's the video just kidding a Muslim
millionaire friend of mine air swiped up
for the interview low on HP I grabbed a
quick Burger coffee combo to Wolf down
for energy and drove over to his place
yummy all right I think this is this is
it what's going on
man awesome bro welcome to the crib uh a
little bit dirty had a couple guests
over but uh yeah this is one of The
Cribs so welcome the Muslim Millionaires
and just their massive places bro well I
want to interview you real quick you
down to go on a a little Drive let's go
on a drive yeah let's talk let's hit
it when did you actually become a
millionaire just right when I probably
turned 19 yeah what was that like when
you finally hit a mill it was like money
directly in my pocket right you hear
people say oh revenue and I make this
much per month but they're not actually
putting it in their pocket so me
actually starting to see put money in my
pocket that was great and that's when I
started seeing like money come in that's
when everything started changing that's
when the lifestyle got upgraded and you
know obviously I was able to help the
people around me so yeah that was great
if you had to start from zero today
where all you had was your brain you
lost your connections all your money but
you just had your brain what would you
do probably I'd get involved in um
something that involves selling products
online or selling services online I'd
start with that take that money and then
put it into products put it into
different things put it into Investments
and then i' just scale out from there
what are like some of your biggest
networking tips that you have for people
a lot about networking is the way that
you introduce yourself like you have to
be able to know how to introduce
yourself to certain people if you're
introducing yourself to someone that is
very big in stock trading or whatever or
a big hedge fund manager you're not
going to say oh yeah um I sell gummy
bears like you're not going to say that
you be like hey like you know I also
know like a lot of people in you know
this industry as well as you uh do you
know this guy do do you know that guy uh
in your industry like you have to build
some type of Rapport you have to build
some type of connection to them and make
them feel comfortable in their
environment and make sure that they know
that you know a little bit about what
they do and you know in return hopefully
you guys can share connection and you
know link up later and you know if it's
whether it's money involved or not
keeping around those people is really
important because you never know when
you're going to need them what's the
importance of making money the Halal
ethical way and not just going for quick
only fans dollars and doing some Haram
ass [__] basically so it's super
important to be morally correct it's
super important to make sure that
everyone gets taken care of it's super
important to make sure that you stick to
those values forever right I have this
crazy story one of my friends he owns a
boat he was renting out the boat so he
found out that while he was renting out
this boat there was people that were on
the boat they were partying drinking and
all
[Music]
this we was lit and
then I just asked you not to [__] up my
boat you just put champagne all over my
$1,000 each one of those cushions is
$1,000 he was not having it you got to
act like you [__] been here
before he said said this I hate this
business people are renting my boat and
drinking and partying and doing all
these degenerate activities what he did
is he sold that boat and he never got
into the business ever again it's always
good to make sure that you're keeping
your money Halal just as other people
you know in the Jewish Community they
keep their money kosher and all these
other uh communities that are more
religious it's very important 100% keep
the money Halal I'm here bro thank you
so much for the interview I appr I have
a couple more boys that I want to to
introduce you to I think you're going to
like them so let's see what happens I
I'll see you next time all right perfect
perfect
bro air is reaching out to some of his
Muslim homies for us so as I'm patiently
waiting on the next brother to interview
I'm going to hit the streets
asking excuse me ma'am are you Muslim no
are you a Muslim no are you Muslim no
are you Muslim no I'm not M 7 hours in
and only one Muslim millionaire
interview down but Luck came through air
hit me up and he actually has a friend
only a few minutes away so let's go meet
up with him and get some more input on
how to get rich
Halal what's your name again mo
mo where the [__] are we this is where
people come to work and I'll [__] around
you think you're more productive working
in an office like this the biggest thing
is if you're sitting somewhere where
people are [__] around then you're
going to [__] around too but if you're
sitting in a in a place where obviously
people are making money getting [__]
done you're also going to get [__] done
too what were your first steps in
entrepreneurship like what did you do
first step was honestly YouTube as
simple as that so first I wanted to be a
YouTuber as soon as I got here but I was
like Ah that's pretty hard and camera
equipment is pretty expensive iPhones
weren't as good as it is now I ended up
doing is I ended up finding a sales job
I found like one of those stupid banners
where you're walking around the hallway
it's like $35 an hour I picked one of
those up and it was uh cutting knives or
selling knives at an office and I went
in there and I'm like there's no chance
like this looks like a scam so I went
instead of doing that I found another
job which was door Tod door sales and
that was kind of my first step into
entrepreneurship at what age did you
become a millionaire I would say it took
me about four years of like actually
hustling grinding figuring out what I'm
really good at until I first my until I
made my first million and then once you
make your first million it's pretty easy
to kind of maintain that and make more
and duplicate your money from there so
it took me about four years and what
industry are you in now Ecom Ecom so
like can you like elaborate a bit more
like you sell like [__] slippers like
what do you so yeah so funny enough I
didn't make my millions in Ecom I
actually made it in crypto but what I
did do was I obviously built skills that
generated me a lot of cash flow and
money through Ecom and then grabb that
money and put it into crypto and that's
where I really made my millions in terms
of what I sell right now we just build
brands that are either feel good or look
good so we either focus on selling
products that make you feel good in
terms of supplement wise or look good in
terms of beauty and cosmetics is that
all Halal money I would say so all of
our products are Halal stamped so yeah
there's there's no gelatin there's no
pork we're not selling drugs or hookers
so it's definitely all H out for sure
how has it been with being an
entrepreneurship especially in Miami
staying um being fully Halal with money
there's so much devilish Temptations
where you can make a lot more money how
is it staying I don't know I guess close
to your soul and like with your morals
yeah I think the biggest thing is just
staying close to God and Allah in
general
so as long as you keep going to the
mosque you keep believing in your faith
and you understand what's good and
what's bad for you then the blueprints
already ran for you like you know in
Islam everything you want to follow is
already in the Quran and anything that's
bad for you is things that are
prohibited from God so as long as you
continue to follow obviously what God
sent you and you be continue to be
ethical and do ethical things then the
Halal will always be there for you and
you never want to go for you know I look
at Haram as like quick money quick money
is never how you build wealth quick
money and quick money out exactly so the
quicker it comes the quicker it goes so
coming from Syria and then making it as
an entrepreneur like what do your
parents think of that they probably
thought like everything I was doing was
a scam or Haram because it's like one
day you're broke you know you're working
at a restaurant as a bus boy and then
the next day you come in with a brand
new $3,000 MacBook and they're like
where the hell did you bring this money
so it took me a few years actually for
my parents to understand you know how I
make my money and where but you know
their number one rule was always like
make sure it's Halo make sure it's like
you're not doing anything illegal what's
your last piece of advice to your Muslim
brothers that are out there trying to
make it an entrepreneurship cuz the
premise of this video is how do people
get rich while sticking with their
morals and not getting sucked into the
devilish Temptations yeah I mean I'm not
going to lie I've been sucked into
Temptations before but luckily because
of the foundation I had I was able to
kind of like stay out of it I would say
the biggest thing that I look at right
now is who are you close with right like
shout out to my boy Fez founder of sweet
dreams actually you know great Muslim
brother always at the mosque always kind
of push me to be the best Muslim I can
so I think the the biggest thing is just
stay close to people who fear God as
well and as long as you're with those
people they push you to continue to be
close to God then you're in in great
hands rather than hit the streets again
you saw how that went we had Mo hit up a
few of his friends to see if they're
down for the interview as well I mean
honestly if you come here bro we have an
amazing spot we've been here for like a
month it's it's beautiful let me show
you should we just slide over should we
just slide
over that is pretty nice take care of
you what do you guys need you guys need
water food you oh [__] I'm tempted yeah
pull up and let me know if you guys want
to eat or anything I'm about to order
food all right sounds good all right
thank you bro see you soon bye see one
thing about Muslims and Arabs you'll
never find anywhere is Hospitality
number one Hospitality anything you need
you see how many times he asks you you
want food you want drinks you want water
yeah no other person will ask you that
before you get there no that's so
[Music]
[Applause]
true
yo bro look at this door wait what are
your names Zan what's good what's up
guys great to meet you H good to meet
you brother awesome great to meet you
boys thank you for coming crushing it in
a Miami highrise right now look at the
view is absolutely beautiful so when did
you guys actually become millionaires
about 4 years ago how long have you been
doing entrepreneurship our whole lives
we've been building businesses for
nearly the past decade together I
remember when Zan was selling
skateboards at the age of 12 so uh I've
had good role models with him and my
father my whole life that's fire what
industry did you guys become
millionaires in where did you make all
your money so initially in the web 2
e-commerce online sales digital
marketing space sold a Shopify store for
like 15K we had drop shipping stores
physical product stores Amazon stores
honestly anything that allows you to
generate money online we've done it
we've tried it yeah and the first Big
Break was Amazon we did seven figures on
Amazon if you guys had to start from
zero like all you have is your brain but
no money no social medias nothing what
would you guys do I would build up a
skill and then provide that skill to the
market and use that skill until I could
build a product or service around it
yeah and I would go find people who I
can you know go work with even if it's
for free and build up those skills and
tone hone those skills so I become
highly effective uh and also can benefit
from their network from you know all the
all the mentorship that they can provide
me because that's going to be like
there's no shortcut to success because
you got to work hard but that's the best
type of shortcut you're going to get
golden advice so far building up a skill
should be your number one priority but I
know a lot of you feel stuck just need
to get up in the morning grab your balls
and look at the flag you see me talking
about it but posting shorts is an
amazing way to make cash right now and
it's what I'm best at so I'm going to be
hosting a free live coaching call to
show you guys how to get started right
away and it's all H cash it's going to
be an hour of free game so you
definitely don't want to miss it the
link to register is at the top of the
description back to asking the
importance of making your money the
ethical halway money simply just
amplifies who who you are so you know we
said it earlier right it's you know
being a millionaire is nice being a
Muslim is better you know if someone
came to me and told me that you can have
all this money but you have to lose your
faith both of us would easily be like
it's all good you know you know we know
what we're doing right but it's very
important to realize that money just
amplifies who you are and essentially
being a m a good Muslim means you're a
good person right you have good
character traits you're a good human
being you're giving back you're
connected to God and you're you're a
servant and you do what he's uh
instructed for us to do on this Earth
and all that means is that when you know
you get your money through bad means
it's only going to amplify bad things in
your life if people can sell their soul
to the devil you have to know that
there's also the good side of it there's
also God and it's it's a fight in this
world between good and evil that's such
an interesting point cuz everyone
acknowledges that these celebrities are
selling their soul and I'm like if you
see that that's automatically proof of
God right cuz they're not it's not a
coincidence if you're going to make 50
million at a life time that's already
guaranteed by God and it's literally
just up to you whether you make that in
the right or the wrong way yeah I mean
for example right pick up your right
foot real quick all right now pick up
your other foot right you can't and
that's basically the distinction between
Destiny and Free Will one is destiny
that amount of money whatever it is
that's destined for you how you made
that money what you did when you got
that money how you thought and what you
did once you had that money did you act
a certain way right or whatever it may
be you know I've always been incredibly
conscious of okay now that I've received
this blessing or whatever it is what am
I doing with these blessings to show God
am I grateful or am I not am I am I
ready for more or am I just you know so
foolish that this came into my life and
I've completely changed as a person
right you want to become a better person
the more money you have you want to be a
more spiritual Muslim and pray more when
you have more wealth and blessings or
whatever may be alhamdulillah it's all a
blessing from God even just having being
born into a Muslim family I it's like
it's the greatest bu that is the bigest
so you know I I wouldn't take credit for
it you know even when people say
self-made millionaire I don't consider
myself made a millionaire because one
we' never even said that we never even
said that I have my brother I have my
dad who I wouldn't be who I am without
them but then if I didn't have God if I
didn't have faith like who would I be
God made
million million God all right boys I
think that was very helpful can you just
give me a quick house tour real quick
ABS the bathroom of a Muslim
Millionaire's Place ooh very nice
very nice kitchen bunch of lads hard at
work they all stared at me as I took
this shot balcony not too shabby of a VI
eh yeah I love my job and the most
important part the table where the Halal
millions are made this is an exact skit
of how those meetings go down 100%
accurate please don't question my uh
journalistic Integrity dude it was great
to having you man you have any more
interviews planned yeah I got one more
really really big one lined up and then
that's about it bro but thank you yeah
of course appreciate it all right see
you guys soon thank
you this big ass
door on to the final boss of the
interviews Ahmad
mud by the way all these interviews came
out to like a half hour long but for the
sake of Miss YouTube Susan not ruining
me I had to cut them down so if you want
to watch the full interviews they're
totally free in my Sunny Faz Discord and
uh okay interview time Ahad it's great
to finally meet you I saw you for the
first time when you're doing like the
Tate stuff you really popped out of
nowhere so you know I appreciate you
taking the time out of your day to do
this interview um just got a C few quick
questions the first one is when did you
actually become a millionaire I became a
millionaire 6 months ago how long were
you in entrepreneurship before hitting
seven figures since 13 years old when I
was in school I was selling lighters and
then I started selling sneakers you know
waiting in line for the new Yeezys and
then started doing Car Sales like luxury
car sales really started working at 13
that was when I did my first influencer
marketing move and then that was the
start of the agency and that's when
really things kicked off with the
sneaker business and that's obviously
the business that made me the most money
what industry are you in right now what
are you what are you grinding at all day
other than Tate interviews uh so the
interview is just for fun you know it's
like how people play sports on the
weekend for me the podcast just purely
fun I barely make money from there my
main source of income is definitely my
influencer marketing agency plug media
so that's really what we what we focus
on if you had start to start from zero
nothing all you had was your brain what
would you do okay it's a good question I
would probably do you know I would say
Ecom because it's such a guaranteed way
to make money if you like put in the
work like Drop Shipping if you willing
to spend the hours it's like almost
guaranteed but I tried it and I find it
really really really boring like I I
hate it so I'd probably end up doing
what I'm doing right now which is
influencer marketing and personal brand
so I'd just start uploading on Tik Tok
three videos a day I can guarantee
anyone watching this video right now if
you upload three videos a day of filming
yourself like yourself actually talking
to the camera three videos a day for
three months and you don't have at least
10,000 followers like I'll give you
$1,000 you know I want to ask you about
the importance of staying religious
you're a Muslim and how important Halal
ethical money is because I even know in
the Quran it talks about the differences
of the types of money that you make I
consider myself pretty religious I'm not
nowhere close to where I want to be but
I pray five times a day you know I try
to avoid sin alost you'll never see me
with like I will never post a girl on my
page one time you know I never have
posted a single picture with a woman so
I'm very careful with my content and I
try my best to stay Halal even when it
comes to agency I've turned down a lot
of deals so I think God is everything
like if you have a lot of money but you
don't have closeness to God you have
nothing you know if you don't believe
you're just you're you're living a life
in nihilism it's just meaningless you're
just waiting to die and when you die
nothing happens so there's no
accountability so I may as well you know
[__] that guy over or kill that guy or
steal from that guy you know because
there no accountability if there's no
gun so even if you don't believe in God
or like it doesn't make sense to you it
would benefit your life and serve you so
much if you did easy money and easy
money out is one of the truest things so
like it not only will you not feel
satisfied it literally bites you in the
ass you see it actually these people who
make money illegal or like unethically
or Haram the way they spend it is insane
like because because they don't know the
value of it because the way they made it
was so easy so you'll see these same
people they'll just blow it on [__] you
know like for example these people do
the casinos they'll just blow million
here or a billion there because and I
don't want to name names you know I
don't have anything any hate in my heart
against any specific influencer or
Creator but what I'm saying is you see
the way they made the money it was felt
easy because that's the way they spend
it so you end up spending that money so
quickly because you don't if you see
like drug dealers for example
historically they're the ones who have
like these flashy cars and these flashy
Lifestyles because they don't know the
value of money because they kind of made
it easily whereas the people who strove
to make like companies and like off the
backs of Labor and grind and sacrifice
they don't spend it the same way and you
need to make it like that because so you
understand the value of it because
otherwise if you got it so easily you're
just going to blow it and then you're
just going to become a degenerate you
know because sometimes blowing that
money you will end up ruining your life
the last thing I want to ask you is I
want to get some networking tips from
you and stuff that you could share with
people watching this video because in
the last I don't know year and a half
I've seen you interview Andrew Tate sneo
fresh and fit you were just in the NOK
boy video I'm pretty sure what do you do
to get these crazy connections I can't
say 100% that this is all my effort I'm
definitely gifted with this kind of
thing it's probably one of my best
attributes about myself so there is a
huge natural element to it but I have
crafted it over time you know so you
know books like How to inflence and
influence people I've read and I've used
those strategies multiple times but I
think one thing that people
underestimate a lot is the real value of
being yourself and I know it sounds so
corny but really like I think people
sense when you're you're someone who's
true to yourself like you are who you
are you know what I mean in this space
with the influencers and all this stuff
it's so like it's like refreshing man
when there's someone who's genuine and
like you can actually it almost feels
like you can like look into them when
you look in their eyes like for example
Tate the reason why I notate I messaged
him when he was just starting to pop off
and I've done that with many many many
big celebrities I hit them up when they
were just on the come up you know and
direct message offering value so Tate
before I did the podcast with him I I
got for him hotel room for free I got
for him a mayback for one month with
24-hour service I arranged for him a sky
not Sky sorry um a desert buggies I
arranged for him jet ski like some of
these stuff we didn't end up going with
it but I had arranged the plans and I
did everything before before I asked him
for anything like I gave all the value
first and then I asked him even when I
asked him I told him there's no string
attached if you say no the cars are
still yours the mayback is still yours
the plans are still planned everything
is going to happen that's the real
that's the juice right there and you
know what's so special about that in my
opinion is you're not just offering him
money you're offering him like an
experience so it's like it's also like
the car the jet skis like while he's on
those memories it's thank you Ahmad Ahad
thank you so much that was extremely
valuable on to the next we got to go
find the next Money musle Millionaire H
money W interviews I am running on 48
hours of sleep I mean staying awake for
4 hours like I said join the sunny Faz
Discord and you will find the full 30
minute interviews there to enjoy and
with that peace guys I'm going to
[Music]
sleep
isation going on there you got yourself
a nice
cream